good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this first edition of our 2023 2024
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grants from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 20 2016 the foundations of
biomedical data science seminar Series
has focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
biomedicine and the Health Sciences this
year's theme is building Partnerships
for generative AI training in biomedical
and clinical research where we will
enjoy presentations on Fridays from
leading thinkers about the issues the
promise the opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging methods in
AI based Technologies applied to
biomedical science data types and the
efforts by faculty Educators in training
the next generation of biomedical
researchers to properly use those
computational tools indeed today we are
excited to announce that we are opening
our 2023 2024 application cycle
encouraging Junior faculty members
working in the area such as the
development of generative AI B based
methods applied to biomedical research
and those Junior faculty actively
utilizing AI in their biomedical
teaching to consider applying we believe
this will be an exciting and engaging
program bringing together AI platform
developers and University Educators to
better understand the power the promise
and the potential perils associated with
Gen the generative AI explosion
participants selected for a biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these seminar presentations as
vital material for our culminating
inperson manuscript and Grant generation
project uh to be held at the Bahia
beachfront Resort located in Sunny San
Diego California in June of
2023 2024 my apologies today I am
delighted to welcome our speaker Dr
Brian Wright from the UVA School of data
science uh Dr Wright is a 2024 BDS
mentor and he is an associate professor
and director of undergraduate programs
at the UVA School of data science prior
to this appointment Dr was the director
of George Washington University's
graduate data science programs and
served as a faculty member teaching
machine learning introduction to data
science and Capstone courses on an
annual basis he also helped to co-found
George Washington University's data
Science Institute and prior to joining
George Washington Dr Wright organized
and led interdisciplinary teams of
researchers at the University of Texas
at
Knoxville he is the founder of DS Labs
LLC and a data science uh consultancy
that focuses on educational program
development algorithm construction and
data science focused research and
development efforts his research sits at
the center of education and data science
and he holds degrees in economics Public
Health Administration and uh higher
education he is currently working to
develop predictive algorithms to
increase Algebra 1 success in K through
12 settings in initiating the 2023 2024
biomedical data science seminar series
theme Brian's lecture today is entitled
generative a AI in context Professor
Wright will talk about the road that led
to the incredible explosion of
generative AI that we are currently
experiencing and that has rapidly
emerged over the past couple of years
creating new research communities around
developing adversarial neural networks
and large language models the results
from which have recently proven
disruptive across public scientific and
educational Spectrum in particular he'll
talk about highlevel architectures that
allow for large language models to be so
effective and conclude with implications
for research moving forward as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube If you are
watching on YouTube thank you so much
for joining us also our specially
selected 2023 2024 by a medical data
science Innovation lab participants in
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions via the chat feature in their
YouTube sessions I will be synthesizing
these questions and will'll ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes
or so of the lecture and with that
welcome Brian thank you so much for
kicking us off this year we look forward
to your lecture thanks for that uh
generous introduction Jack and I'm happy
to be here and uh let's go ahead and
Jump Right In I got I got one quick
change for the introduction you said
University of Texas that's University of
Tennessee I beg your partner Tennessee
no no no I my uh my fellow colleagues
from there would be uh would be remiss
if I didn't jump in but anyway um thanks
again jack uh this is great so I I'm
just going to go over um this uh kind of
agenda here real quick uh going to lay
out a little bit of data science
Concepts uh I got a little bit of a poll
I think for the audience too because I'm
not totally sure um kind of the level of
expertise I'm dealing with here so I can
adjust the the talk a little bit based
off those responses but the meat of it
here is kind of oriented around how did
we get here um uh so I'll talk about the
evolution of the field uh a little bit
of history but we'll get through it real
quick and then we'll talk specifically
about kind of large language models and
the current you know generative AI boom
that we have and and to Jack's Point
kind of end with some concerns so here I
have a quick poll you can hit the QR
code up there you can think of this as
like a scale from top to bottom you know
that you what is your experience in
terms of relative knowledge of data
science you know if you feel like you
you embody data science wholly you can
hit that first one but if you're not
sure about the field you're just getting
started maybe you're all the way down
there on the bottom uh and that'll just
help me kind of
context the the talk in
general so there we go all right we do
have one person that is embodying data
ass signs that's good to know okay very
good I'll give it a few minutes there's
probably a bit of a lag and we're not
totally sure how many people we have on
the other end but we'll go from go from
what responses we
get there we go okay we got a couple
more people I've been using ml for many
years all right very
good
right
been planning to use it for many years
all right very
good give it a few more moments
here see if we get some more
responses
all right well let's let's go ahead and
move on it might be that we get a few
more people that jump on that poll kind
of as we move throughout but that's
that's no problem so it looks like it's
kind of a kind of a split right so all
right we got one more all right so we
got a little bit of a this data science
thing you say all right uh so I'll
probably jump through maybe some of the
front end ones but kind of stick to the
original plan here uh so let's give just
a quick overview of some of these data
science Concepts so in particular here
at this at UVA we have kind of this uh
Paradigm that we have embodied about the
way we think of the field of data
science and it's composed of these four
components I'm not going to get into
this there's a whole dissertation
associated with this but in large part
what we're talking about large language
models generative AI it's in this
analytics category you know value you
can think of Ethics systems you can
think of cloud computing design you can
think of data visualizations or human
centered design so that's the way that
we think about it um in the school we
have curriculum kind of designed around
that but you know in this particular
talk especially as it relates to AI
we're focusing on that and analytics
piece and again based off those
responses I think a lot of people are
familiar with this but I like to break
down analytics just to think of it not
just as machine learning but there's
also these components of Applied
Mathematics all right statistical
Concepts and then and then AI all right
so AI is the Big 10 I think that's going
to spin uh and so when we think about
that all right again just given the
diversity of the audience right
artificial intelligence is the big is
the big sector all right machine
learning is a subset of artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
going to be everything from just simple
software engineering that helps
um that helps computers think like
humans right that might be coding
certain uh as an example coding certain
interfaces between um various
medications to make sure that there's
not any type of conflict to prescribe
those to uh to individual patients that
doesn't require any type of fancy
machine learning that's just simple
software all right but that helps in
decision making right machine learning
when we go down inside the AI Spectrum
we think of that as kind of more like
probability istic learning like what are
you know kind of learning without being
specifically coded and then deep
learning which is where kind of the big
boom associated with AI and generative
AI in particular is really the focus of
this particular year um for this program
and then also kind of the focus of the
talk so it just helps contextualize that
for everybody and it sounds like you
know a good amount of people on The Talk
know this but the context with which
we're talking about this deep learning
is actually kind of a very small portion
it is the one that gets the most
attention by far but it is a smaller
portion um of a larger big AI 10 all
right I just went through these so I
don't have to dig too much more into
that but these are kind of General
examples of like classical AI machine
learning that might be just product
recommendations and then deep learning
is really the kind of the large language
models or neural network applications in
particular all right okay so this is
important context to is we go further
down right in terms of like the the
level of AI you just have a more
predictive power but they're less
explainable so explainable should be on
the bottom on the bottom bar there and
we're going to send most of our time up
in the top this is just a look again
across the landscape of machine learning
and you can see kind of in the bottom
there that neural networks all right is
kind of a subset of the larger world of
machine learning and this chart's a
little old it probably should be updated
um in particular to add some of the new
methods um that are starting to come out
okay okay so um important part here to
keep in context you we think of machine
learning as really kind of a general
purpose technology that means they can
apply it across all sorts of different
Market sectors you know whether you want
to elevate it to the level of
electricity in the internet maybe not
but anyway that's the way that we think
of it so again in good context and part
of the reason that we're here is to
learn about how we can apply in
particular to biomedical
situations all right I'm going to skip
over that all right and these are just
kind of contemporary points all right so
what we've seen especially over you know
since 2010 there was this big com of um
Milestone there associated with the
error rate of classification and image
net it went way down you know less than
5% and the important part behind that is
that's because that's um that's lower
than the human error rate all right so
what we know is as humans were to look
at this there's about a 5% error so it
got below kind of the human error rate
and that started happen around 2010 one
of these first big deep uh Learning
Systems was deep blue that was purchased
there's a European company that ended up
getting purchased by Google it's kind of
the corner St of their um you know Aid
driven efforts
internally um and then you know as we
move along what we found and this is
just recently there's been another the
same that same product right that deep
blue kind
of deep level architecture was used in
in another game for go um that is much
more complicated than chess right and
then that that Alpha go was the product
that was generated there but just
recently um you know a simple trick by
an amateur was able to beat the computer
I think 18 out of 19 times right
happened sometime in the last six months
and so no matter how good um I think
anyway no matter how good these machines
get and they're approving just at an
incredible scale all right there still
is some need for human expertise and
experience along the way so I think it's
an important reminder as we go through
all of this we have really Advanced
obviously machine learning and
generative AI product tools but there's
still kind of uh use cases and examples
where if we just keep human in the loop
that they end up working better or they
can kind of beat them even if the most
Advanced even if the most advanced uh
examples of that all
right so uh again this is just kind of
context these are things that our humans
are good at but this is things that
machines are good at and again kind of
interpreting and using the results I
think is the key one with the check mark
under the human there that we should
keep in mind all right so I blew through
that really quick I always uh always
look for excuses to build in uh Back to
the Future memes so there's one here so
the question is like how did we get to
this point all right so let's let's take
a a look at that oh this is much fuzzier
than I thought it would be but this is
generally a timeline associated with the
development of intelle know AI based
Frameworks over time uh and what we'll
see right especially towards the end
here all right all right it's kind of a
rapid development in terms of the
integration between machine learning
developed kind of in the private sector
and then in combination with what's
going on in uh the academic all right so
let me let just jump ahead of this and I
think right here right
I mean the main takeaway from this and
again this is what most people are kind
of familiar with this the nature of this
is that a lot of these artificial
intelligence Methods at least the
foundation of them had been in
development or at least um Being Framed
out in uh academic circles for decades
you know as far back as the
1960s all right but it really wasn't
until the first part this of the 2010s
right when they started to get a ton of
notice um from the private sector about
how powerful these tools could be as it
relates to leveraging the business
models that were occurring especially in
the you know kind of social media and um
you know internet search engine world
all right and so right about this time
20 2009 2012 what we start to see is
kind of this combination of all this
long Heritage of academic work all right
starting to create um really um
momentum inside the big Tech firms of
the day and so a lot of people point to
this kind of 200 n you know when Al Val
Herring started to come out and talk
about kind of you know that that the you
know Google's Chief Economist saying hey
that this is going to be you know
statisticians are going to be in high
demand and then there's kind of this
famous article in 2012 the Harvest
Business Review that called data
scientist kind of the sexist job in the
21st century so all these years of
progression right kind of led up to kind
of this fluctuation point where popular
kind of um attention in the in the media
and in the private sector really started
to notice about how important these
things were going to be be all right and
there's there's a bunch of reasons for
this this is just to take note of of
hinton's influence in terms of this
timeline right the the amount of
contribution that he made throughout is
not to be
understated and so we can take a look at
this timeline right to just put it in
more context if you haven't been to this
before this is this is an engram viewer
um from Google and essentially tracks
word usage over time in their digital
libraries all right so here what we're
searching for is artificial intelligence
data science machine learning and maybe
to nobody's surprise right and just to
reinforce the ideal that we were talking
about here is that you know there was
this big bump you know even back in the
in the 1990s right and then again in
kind of the early
2000s um and but it went up and down
right and so the question is and people
refer to these as kind of the AI Winters
but I put some I put some stars in here
and I'm going to try and contextualize I
think why and maybe it's obvious but why
exactly we saw kind of this recent
takeoff and then how all of this history
kind of built up to this this moment in
2015 that really that really catapulted
us into this generative AI
space so let's talk about that in
particular all
right all right so here right early
2000s I think you know a derivative of a
little bit of an increase there is what
we saw is the you know the mass
production of Nvidia gpus that started
to happen right at the beginning of the
2000s and as we know like a lot of these
big data and especially these deep
architectures really depend on now they
they've moved on right to New U more
advanced kind of Hardware but that
started to help us realize the power of
these models that just wasn't available
before all right so we had kind of a
hardware contribution in the early 2000s
and we saw kind of a spike there right
after that all right it's kind a housing
bubble everything went down after that
that's an excuse for maybe the the kind
of reduction that we saw all
right so we had we had a lot of these U
mathematical softwares been developed or
mathematical procedures that had been
developed in
academic uh circles for years all right
but then we had this Hardware
contribution and then we saw a software
contribution that allowed us to link
distributed networks together
efficiently all right that hadn't been
available really before there would been
methods before but spark in particular
allowed us to really combine this kind
of computing architectures in
combination with the hardware all right
those two things together really kind of
laying the foundation for what would be
just a perfect development environment
kind of leading into the 2015s all right
and so here I think is really where we
saw kind of this punctuated equilibrium
all right so we have we had Hardware
that was in place that could that could
support the computational needs that
were necessary all right we saw some of
this open source software that allowed
those computers to be linked together in
uh in sophisticated ways that hadn't
been available before at least it became
much more efficient and then also right
around this time like right around 2015
the accumulation of data
uh starts to really take off um it had
always been growing right through the
early 2000s especially with the creation
of the internet a lot of people point to
the create um the mass production of uh
iPhones in the early 2010s as a real
dramatic increase in the amount of
available data and so there's statistics
here right in 2009 that 90% of the
world's data have been created basically
in the last three or four years and you
can see that with the explosion of
internet based companies right with the
explosion of mobile um Hardware and cell
phones that was a huge point right so we
had we had the hardware in place we had
kind of an ability to connect those
together and now what we've seen over
that period right after that is this
massive expansion in data right and so
at that same time Google and they were
kind of you know one of the first to
field here right with their deep blue
engine they see these massive increases
in the performance of their AI based
platforms right and so as a catalyst to
that and I think it's because of that as
I mentioned kind of preceding this slide
with about how things were folding out
in the private sector in combination
with the uh you know kind of
contemporary media around Ai and data
science you saw academic institutions
starting to respond dramatically to the
demand from the private sector to create
degrees to support the expansion of this
Workforce so at that same time right in
2012 20 you know leading up to 2015 we
see a huge increase especially in the
graduate programs Masters in data
science Masters in Business analytics it
just it just went crazy and in
combination with that the demand signal
from the research Community also
increased dramatically as it you know I
think as a as a driving force for some
of these big Tech firms they were doing
their own internal research incubators
right they were really trying to put a
lot of phds um you know a lot of human
capital in the development of these
Technologies because they started to see
really crazy increases in the
performance of their models right in
that period of time so to reinforce this
uh ideal I have here the same thing if
we add data set to that distribution
that you just saw it's exact same as
this we just added the word data set it
just dwarfs the others there right so
the expansion of data if this is a
measure of how often that is used in
public discourse which is supposed to be
we can see that this you know the
increase here just dwarfs the kind of
the percentage increases we see in these
other three areas to reinforce the idea
of the massive amount of increases of
data that was occurring right at that
same time all right so this is a chart
from Michael Raa he was one of the first
uh analytics programs really kind people
some some say one of the first data
science specific programs at NC State
and he's been tracking the increase in
in graduate programs over the last I
mean 12 years so here you can see again
right around that 2014 2015 time frame
it's just an explosion in the number of
programs from 2010 which might be less
than 20 you know to to to 2015 where
you're looking at 200 and then moving
into 300 and then continuing to grow uh
into the early 2020 so that reinforces
this idea you know this second bullet
here about this dramatic increase in the
workforce that we saw all right this is
a chart from from Springer they're
tracking kind of Big Data Publications
that were occurring over time and again
it right here in that same sweet spot
you know 2010 to 2019 you just see this
huge increase in the number of
Publications I mean from down there in
the zeros to up to you know pushing
8,000 in a period of what five or six
years I mean so again it's this
combination of investment
from from the private sector attention
from Academia and kind of leveraging
these uh methods that already been
placed for a long time the increases
that we saw in availability of data and
then the you know the the Computing
infrastructure both in hardware and
software that were available be able to
Catalyst it just created this perfect
incubator for this explosion in methods
all right and it's all kind of leading
up to this AI Revolution that we've seen
over the last I don't know two to three
years and so the question is and leading
into this kind of Stark um increase in
artificial intelligence what is that
what is that particular star so let's
let's get a little bit more detailed in
the terms of what we're thinking about
for generative AI in particular and then
and then and actually specifically kind
of large language
models
okay all
right so a lot of the work here I just
wanted to give Credence to uh to Raphael
Alvarado he put a lot of this together
he's an anthropologist but specializes
in kind of text analysis here in the
school of data science so he let me
borrowed some of his some of his slides
for this but they're they're perfectly
gerine for this talk so I'm going to
include him there so thanks Raph for
that I appreciate it all right so let's
talk about large language models in
particular okay so uh you know based off
what we know right so um more
specifically these large language models
what they're doing is they're really
trying to predict the next token all
right which is really just another word
right so they're autoaggressive so
they're very dependent on what happened
right before that next prediction but
they can use billions of weights all
right inside these deep neural networks
Frameworks okay but it all boils down to
basically trying to predict what the
next word is oh my God the volcano is
about to right erupt all right so in
this examp I just wanted to lay that
context is that it can be distilled down
just into that simple output obviously
the architectures that underneath these
things are quite complicated but the
idea is just to predict kind of the next
sequence of words all right now this is
an
example of what a gp2 right this is an
older version of it that can actually be
run just on a desktop but just to
reinforce this idea right so what you
see down here on the bottom all right
this is a this is a Transformer that's
the architecture the AI architecture
associated with this particular
particular this particular framework and
that's the same framework that supports
GPT and chat and it's and the
application chat GPT all right but here
what we're doing is we're trying to
predict the next word you can see down
here in this sentence the best thing
about AI is its ability to and then
what's going to happen is that you're
going to have essentially a vector here
right of different words and their
likelihood to show up based off the um
based off the data that this
architecture has in place what is the
most likely word to show up next in this
sequence of words all right and what
we're doing is we're outputting here
just the top probability we're just
doing the top 20 probabilities here and
they're not in order I probably should
have should have done that but what
we'll see here is its ability to learn
is actually the next
best object but at the end of the day
right if you distill these down that's
the goal right is them for them to them
to to be able to predict essentially
what this next token is going to be uh
based off the previous uh set of words
that it's given and and it does a really
good job about this so if we look back
like at the technologies that support it
one of the key ones and again these are
there's a list here but in 2013 all
right word DEC was invented all right
which is an important part but also it
was followed up by um something called
the distribut uh distributional
hypothesis right and that the idea
behind the distributional hypothesis and
I think I have a slide to it so I'll
talk a little bit more to that is that
words that are close together
have similar meaning and they can be
predicted based off the VAR based off
the various distance the likelihood that
they far far apart they are in large
corai of text so this is important right
so we realize that okay we don't have to
actually create you know fairly
structured models to be able to
interpret grammar we can just use
essentially the location of the words as
a vehicle for predicting how good it
will fit in the next sentence right so
this distributional hypothesis this was
key to kind of creating these large
language
models and as we look through these
sequence of things again I just want to
highlight a few of these all right not
to talk through them and a
naum in 2014 attention was created as
basically another hyperparameter
associated with um large language models
and attention is essentially you can
think of it as the emphasis on any one
word the importance of any one word in a
sentence all right
uh and so if you can assign attention so
there's different there's different
examples of this so if we to say you
know the cat is black all right so in
that particular sentence right the word
black is very important for cat right
but if we were to say as an example you
know there's both a a black cat and a
white cat it might be that the
distribution associated with those two
words white and black are equal as
compared to more attention that was
given on the first sentence that might
be a bad example but the idea of it is a
essentially how much um how important is
any one word to understanding the entire
string of words in which it's embedded
all right and so Transformers were also
invented in 2017 all right which is a
new architecture associated with
essentially it was designed to translate
language but much of that architecture
actually the the majority of that
architecture is what used under the hood
for large language models uh currently
in terms of their generating um terms of
their applications particularly in GPT
right so it's used there so it's the
kind of the AI architecture driving a
lot of the a lot of these large language
models and what we found right is
that uh instead of uh including a lot of
the other parameters associated with how
these models are trained is that
attention ends up being kind of the key
component right so these Transformers
helped us move away from recurring
neural networks as a baseline
architecture for um generative large
language models and then attention which
was created in 2014 ended up being the
key component in order for them to
really perform at a high level so it's
really these combinations of things it's
attention mechanism all right and then
also this new architecture associated
with Transformers that allowed us to
kind of move forward in this GPT world
and we can see right after this in 2018
new TBT is pre-trained with a
Transformer model all right and then
Bert and Google suddenly they're
announcing to they're moving off of
recurring neural networks and using this
Transformer model with that attention
component and then it just kind of
skyrockets from there and so gpt2 is the
one that I showed kind of in the
snapshot there about the way it's
predicting just with the probabilities
but a lot of these um components put
themselves in place right in
combination I talked about this so I
think I'll skip over this all right in
combination with these features right in
the timeline that we talked about here
right so what we saw and that's what the
question mark is there really that's the
Transformer and attention architectures
so we have had again not to review it
all but we had all of these components
that kind of came together at this like
perfect moment right where they saw like
really these increases in Ai and then we
had the correct architecture that was
that was able to take advantage of all
this previous work and that's why we saw
this just massive increase in the in the
use and proliferation of AI we know we
had this you know kind of you know
generative AI Revolution that we're in
for the last two years it's kind of a
combination of all this kind of slow
burn and then suddenly right there
kindor right in 2017 and 18 is when
things just went just went through the
roof all right so let's talk a little
bit more about how these models work and
I think it's important to just
contextualize that that there's one
other component of the of the large
language models that's really important
I think I put it here so there's kind of
these three
key enhancements right so we talked
about attention and then there's
position that's basically the position
of the words that's kind of the word to
vet concept and there's also this thing
thing called temperature all right so if
you understand these three things about
these um Transformer models these large
langu large language models right then
you kind of have a general high level
idea about how they're working all right
so attention is an important one and so
what attention tells us is essentially
what order that we're going to select
the next probable the next probabilistic
word to choose right and that's that's
kind of a word salad there but the idea
is that it's not it might not always be
best to pick the word with the highest
probability is that you might have to
adjust and this is what the temperature
does essentially adjusts you know uh at
random how random we want that next word
to be as compared to just picking the
top probability which in this example
would be would be learn all right so
this is an example so I just again we
let this run a little bit more right so
here we was just continuing to build out
this is build out this large language
model you can see we're adding you know
new words step by step learn from
experience it's not just it's not just a
matter of all right so we're basically
just letting this run to add another 10
words to it but what we find is that if
we don't adjust the temperature this is
the result we get all right so this is
an example from from Steven Wolfram all
right so he did he went through this
experiment and showed this online and
the idea here is that if the temperature
is set to zero that means that it takes
the top probabilistic word that is that
is predicted uh every time what happens
is is you get this you start to see
essentially uh just a a repetition all
right it just starts to repeat in a
cycle because the next likely word is
going to be based off what was done
before and if there's no variability
it's just going to start to repeat so we
see that here this is a temperature of
zero all right but if we increase this
is a temperature of 08 you can go from 0
to one in most of these models what we
see is a much more elegant sentence all
right so here what it's doing is it's
randomly selecting all right from that
list of possible words not choosing the
top possible word and that's what
generates this type of much more kind of
elegant sentence and this was an
advancement that allowed for large
language models to really produce high
quality text in combination with the new
Transformer architecture and then also a
lot of the advancements that we've
talked about relative to Hardware
software and just um modeling approaches
but this was a key one too all
right all right so some of the problems
with this all right is that if you
inherently increase the temperature and
this may be kind of um obvious but if
you increase that temperature
um parameter all right what you're doing
essentially is selecting but it is from
a high you know high density of of of
predictions but what you're doing is you
you are selecting at random what the
next best word might be all right and so
what happens is that if for some reason
that random selection of a word right
isn't exactly Perfect all right it can
Reser in in what we in what has been
commonly referred to as hallucinations
right is that essentially what happens
because these things are autor
regressive which means that it's heavily
dependent on the accuracy of the
previous prediction is that once it
starts to go off the rails it goes off
the rails really quickly and that can
sometime result in what we've been what
we've been seeing in terms of these
hallucinations right just because the
nature of them is that they're autor
regressive right so they're using the
previous previous predictions to do the
ones in the future and if those are
slightly outside of the distribution of
the data that the model has access to
then it's going to go off the rails
pretty quick kind of as we see is our
comic over here right they just don't
know how deep the water is I think it's
a good way to think about we just don't
know how close we are to those errors
suddenly um something going off the side
of a cliff
right all right and so this this is an
example here it's kind of a kind of a
clunky graphic but I do think like over
time what's happened right is that the
models have gradually increased all
right but you always have kind of this
leakage or's kind of this dripping down
here on the bottom and you can think of
the leakage as like how far can we push
these models until we realize that we
see above the surface and we're like
okay this is you know it's giving me
some pretty clear hallucinations here
all right you know this was this was
seen a lot in the early days I think
when gp22 was out they acted really
simple logic questions it would just get
them wrong uh and we've seen it I think
continue with gpt3 especially rela to um
you know current events things like that
they're just probably aren't in its
distribution of information that stopped
in
2021 and so what's happening is I think
the models are getting better and better
it's getting deeper and deeper so the
idea here is that it's hard for us um
the users to get above that surface and
really see the errors but they're always
going to kind of be there and so over
time it might be that these models are
so deep that it just never happens but
it's important remember there's always
going to be a certain amount of error
kind of leaking at the bottom of these
just given the nature of how they're
trained and used which can make them and
in my experience and working with some
local firms to put them into production
can make kind of difficult to use
especially if you want to have uh
repeatable authoritative information um
coming out of them um and that that that
can be quite quite difficult um
okay so keep going here all right uh and
then I'll get to I'll get to potential
concerns all right I I'm conscious of
the time here I think got about another
10 minutes or so
um and many of you may have seen these I
think it's important to bring it up you
know that there's kind of these open uh
and and lots of AI researchers and
people that were generating these models
signed on to some of these to have a you
know kind of a pause I think this was
about a year ago to say hey let's just
wait six months I mean I don't I don't
know what six months would have would
have made any different but there are
some concerns um relative to the rapid
development of these models and there
was just another one this is just an
excerpt from that letter talking about
you know that uh we're going to achieve
human competitive intelligence and a
profound risk to society and Humanity I
think that's true but I think if um you
know we have a real good understanding
of the limitations of these models just
like we talked about and you start to
really use them over and over again I
think think a lot of this was a bit
overstated this one maybe in particular
I think that there were some concerns I
don't know people remember this about uh
the potential uh nuclear war likee event
you know if AI was uh to continue to
proliferate and maybe they're talking
about decades into the future I'm not
quite uh quite as concerned about this
but it is this was signed on by a lot of
really famous um AI researchers in the
community and brought up as kind of a
continuous thing to think about at a
minimum all right and there's some
misinformation that scale could be a big
problem especially with the large
language models in terms of the way that
they're generating text you know can be
done quite easily
and we do we are in a period of really
rapid development and I'm just going to
I'm going to let this run I don't know
if I can yeah I show you
this all right so this is a program
that's using GPT in the background but
doing kind of automated search online
so you just kind of release it to the
wild I mean even this is a bit dated now
I think this is you know kind of a six
months ago kind of an
example but I think what we're going to
see I'll just pause this all right but
this is just an example this is just a
simple piece of software that's using
GPT in the background but it's been
trained in a way where it actually goes
out on the internet and starts to learn
about any particular Topic in this
example it's learning about itself
actually um and then generating
summarized text based off of that so I I
think what we're going to see and this
is a good use case of it is like more
and more embedding into applications you
know kind of without without guard rails
generally I think there's been just kind
of a really a push to include this maybe
maybe in spaces that make a lot of sense
but um you know in some spaces maybe
that it doesn't um and this is just the
beginning right so I think given that
the technology is out there and open you
know kind of the development around
integrating it into kind of
user-friendly applications and then the
combination of um uh you know whether
that's able to generate text from
prompts or generate um images from
prompts or generate um you know even um
even language right even spoken word
from prompts I think it's going to be
another thing so you see these these
Integrations between audio and video and
text which is already starting to occur
which could be really exciting but also
kind of um you know a little bit a
little bit scary as it relates to kind
of you know how fast these Technologies
are moving
forward all right another thing uh
associated with this when we think about
kind of you know what are we concerned
about is we do have really kind of a
push in the US for um you know open
development you know there's not a whole
lot of regulations this is the European
model for for people that that may be
familiar with the gdpr there that's kind
of their General data protection um you
know architecture um that's available
and we don't necessarily have that in
the US there's some that's kind of close
to it just California version of it
which provides for some oversight and
protection of of personal data but
generally we really don't have these
restrictions which is part of the big
reason that GPT was able to um an open
AI in particular was able to develop um
these models so quickly they had so much
access to so much data basically online
there was no restrictions about what
they could
use we also have a lot of competition I
think so this chart all right is an
example of the parameter space of large
language models um kind of mostly from
domestic domestic kind of companies but
also in the Chinese and kind of other
Global spaces and you can see we don't
necessarily have a uh a total Market
capture on this you know there there are
tons and tons of these models large
language models that are being developed
and put out into the open all right so I
mean that's another thing relative to um
the space of this and the competition
which I think is it can be a really good
thing to help push these models forward
and kind of Advance development so if
you put all these kind of combinations
in place you know the competition um
kind of the nature of um I'll just go
down to this you know kind of the rapid
development Global competition you know
in the free market I think what we'll
see is just the the and then the
development and advance advancement and
technology and availability data we're
just going to continue to see these
models kind of grow uh and continue to
proliferate over time because of all
these things that have been put put into
place um which makes it a very exciting
time to think about applications and how
they can be used in research things like
that you have to be a little bit
concerned you know that there might be
some uh potential calamities associated
with all these things being put into
place but uh but you know in general I'm
you know I'm fairly bullish I think that
this is going to be a toal net positive
and that you know the advancements that
we're seeing in this is going to be a uh
you know really a really um dramatic
increase in our efficiency and our
ability to be able to produce uh you
know really interesting products and and
certainly push research aspects
forward all right uh so I have some
final kind of specifications here um I
will say you know a regulatory framework
I think uh is is hopeful I guess the
people in conversations that a little
bit more Savvy into the space including
um researchers here the school of data
science that focus on policy they
believe that a Europe like a European
like model could be present in the
future in the US I'm not sure exactly
what that might look like but I think it
would probably be more of a watered down
version but I I think that would be
healthy relative to the development of
these things and create some type of
guard rails you know as an example Bard
is not available in the EU right now
based off how their regulatory framework
um uh is in place it is it does seem to
be clear that you know the increased
cost of keeping these models is quite
high right that it's important to
remember the latest version gp4 stops um
relative to its data set in 2021 all
right by some estimations you to train
one version of this is something like
the energy used for midow you know
midsize City for an entire year um for
GT4 gp4 cost close to hundred million
doar to train all right so
explainability ends up ends up being
kind of a big issue relative to this
when I showed that kind of in that chart
at the very beginning to contextualize
what we're talking about as you move
further and further down kind of into
the deep architectures being able to
understand exactly how they're working
uh can be quite complicated um doesn't
mean that they um don't work really well
and that there aren't some ways and I
think actually explainable AI is moving
on uh pretty rapidly and I think
actually that's going to be a nice area
to think about um in terms of expansion
for research areas it almost is like a
uh almost as like a push back I think to
the development of some of this kind of
generative AI that may the explainable
AI space might actually become pretty
popular for some people um to generate
models that work just as well that are a
bit better
understood so uh you know I think
approaches for fine-tuning AI models and
collaborations with um you know with
clients or researchers espe to be more
common um you know in my working with um
with companies here and then also you
know just in talking with people that
are working to deploy these it seems
that's ends up being um the majority of
the time you know because you have kind
of these pre-trained models already and
you can pick them up and use them but
then fine tuning them on the back end
for your particular use case you know
kind of a reinforced learning approach
ends up being um the majority of the
work and uh I think that's good and I
think it also at some places you know
need to create a um you know a framework
for at what point does it not make sense
to continue to try and do that right and
maybe use another approach that doesn't
require so much fine-tuning and I think
that that's a that's a space where
people are going to start to make
choices about whether they want to use
generative AI or maybe to go back to
more I mean I guess we could say this
you know more traditional kind of AI
approaches that don't necessarily
require you know the generation of new
of new text or images or sound or Voice
or video whatever that might be
um so I think that so that's it I I went
through that really really kind of fast
but um Jack I think I got is that 15
minutes for questions is that kind of
the way that we go yes perfect Brian
thank you thank you so much for giving
us this overview I this was really
helpful for me and helping to give me a
little more of the context um certainly
it seems like in the last oh 18 months
or so I mean the last nine months we
have seen just such an explosion with
you know it's like one of these things
where a sequel to a movie comes out and
it's like you know son of zor you know
returns again right he like well what
was the original zor movie I didn't see
that one but now there's like I'm seeing
the advertising for the sequel It's like
chat gpt3 I didn't know there were
several others before that and so it's
like seems like it's just arrived so
it's so sudden and I'm wondering if
that's part of one of the drivers of
people's fears about this is it just
seems like it happened over
night yeah 100% I mean I I and it it
just it when I started to look look into
this and I was trying to better
understand it myself I mean me I mean me
and you are both in schools of data
science and to a certain extent like the
explosion of of this even caught us off
guard I mean I think it did you know so
uh we spent a lot of time doing kind of
like a like a postto and be like whoa
how did this how did this happen I mean
part of it was just relative to the the
ease of use of that of chat GPT uh in
particular um just made it it made it
very accessible and so even these
methods you know they were kind of in
place in house in these big Tech firms
you know when that became online and the
user interface became so simple then
people just that that was a big reason
for it but also I think when we started
to look back it like had the Slow Burn
kind of and maybe not even slow right
but kind of the rapid development of of
Technologies and software and data
expansion in the last like seven to
eight years it was almost like Manifest
Destiny that as soon as the technology
as soon as the mathematical approaches
the AI architecture became available it
just took off because everything else
was in place yeah and um that just made
it you know it made essentially the
foundation for kind of sharpening the
pointy end of that spear possible
because before you know maybe maybe it's
a bad but the spear just didn't really
exist and then all of a sudden it was
there and it allowed it to um to really
explode yeah it's interesting how these
perfect storms of things kind of can
happen right it's only when you had the
Confluence of all of these different
Technologies just all were you know at
there at the same time that they got put
together and then there's just this
explosion of innovation in this area
it's fascinating yeah and the other
really interesting thing people people
don't talk about it enough is that how
how the big Tech firms espe esally for
the attention vehicle open sourced those
Innovations and that allowed open AI the
company at that time to take the
innovations that were generated in
Google and create
GPT I mean so if that hadn't been like
an open you know research process they
never would have been able to leverage
that technology to accomplish and now
they have a multi-billion dollar company
as a result of it which is also really
interesting yeah you know and it's
interesting you know you were talking
about what the cost is to train these
models and you know that it takes the
power of a small nation to be able to do
as probably a lot of money as well but
you still have these phenomenon like uh
you know the models hallucinating and
one of our uh comments from one of our
viewers is asking like how do you tell
the difference between a model that just
wasn't trained on something and just
doesn't happen to know versus it's
hallucinating how do you tell the
difference
it's a good question essentially it's
the same thing so what we find is that
hallucinations occur in particular when
prompts are given um to large language
models when the answers are outside of a
density of distribution of information
that has available so like as an example
like if we know that uh you know gp4 was
trained on information prior to 2021 it
knows a lot about presidents it can tell
you a ton about presidential procedure
like the history like what the
Presidential Power it could do a lot
about that but it can't really tell you
a lot about how Biden implements his
version of his presidential you know
presidential Powers right because it
doesn't have a lot of density of
information on him in particular right
so that's that's that's kind of what we
see is that those hallucinations have a
tendency to occur um because of there's
not enough information in the
distribution of data that it has
available to it and that's why you see a
lot of energy going into fine-tuning you
know and it's almost like it's almost
like whacka all you know like you you
you push these you push these models and
push them and push them and then all of
a sudden there's another set of
information that it just doesn't it just
doesn't know enough about it to
accurately generate text around that so
you have to kind of put a bandaid on it
and say all right well let's eliminate
this from the range of things that it
could ask and that's when you get the
prompt and say hey I'm not too sure on
this you know you may want to think
about asking it another way and so
that's that's where kind of that you
know how you F to to end of those models
to make sure that they're not don't have
an expansive kind of uh perimeter set
you know that kind of control the span
of the things that they have expertise
on and don't but when you're talking
about you know training it on the entire
Internet it's almost impossible to do
that you know to say hey these are
things that can know and not know so the
the hallucination effect is essentially
infinite because you can't go in and and
correct every possible um error that
might occur yeah you know and another
thing which is kind of interesting is
you might think okay how could it you
know keep up with its knowledge base
right so you might imagine that it would
pick a number of you know New York Times
or CNN or whatever your favorite news
source is and ingest that information
and use it in training its models but
then of course the the chat GPT and
other Technologies like this are
generating the content um in you know
where might expect that they would in
the future generating that same content
you almost get this sense of like a
snake eating its own tail in terms of
its training at some point you know uh a
human being in the loop is probably
important somehow how do we keep a Reign
on that is that even a sensible question
no no it makes it makes a lot of sense
and it it hearkens back to kind of a
first mover in this you know you know
ethics of data science field which was
which Kathy which Kathy O'Neal Who
Affiliated here um at UVA
um and she you know put out this book
called weapons of maass Destruction and
one of the four key components
associated with you know an algorithm
that maybe has gone Ry is essentially
it's it's eating its own dog food right
and so it's generating information that
then gets put back in to the training
set and then is used for generating you
know predictions uh moving forward that
it's affected the landscape of the
information it receives so much that
it's actually generating um the
information that it gets trained on and
that's that's like you said like the
snake eating its tail so I I think it at
one at at some point what starts which
just like any other algorithm that gets
put out into the wild regardless of how
big it is you know it may cost a hundred
million dollars but and and you have to
keep track of how often these errors are
occurring like how often is it
hallucinating and recently actually
there's been a lot of interesting
research at least you know kind of um
you know maybe you know desktop research
associated with the idea that GPT is
actually getting Dumber you know is that
things that it was getting right not
that long ago it's starting to get wrong
now and that it's starting to
essentially it's this you know enthropy
principle right is that as the expansion
of the things that it's being asked to
do continues to grow it's just getting
worse and worse at it and then at some
point you just need to stop and retrain
yeah yeah exactly it's it's almost a
continuous training process right it's
it can't you can't just train it then
use it and it's going to slowly drift
out of out of alignment or out of
calibration right it needs to be
calibrated but on a continuous basis in
order to just keep up yeah I think it's
exactly that and then with the scale of
cost associated with with doing that
retraining you have you have to start to
think that um you know is that model
sustainable I mean I I don't know I mean
it it it might not be um and so then I
think you know there's been a there's
been kind of a movement especially with
some of the the examples I've seen to
get away from using the all-encompassing
Corpus of uh large language models
trained on the entire internet and then
do much more specialized training you
know in terms of more local Corp ey that
you can use so it's really good and that
this is the same thing that happened
with go and chess like all these they're
trained on a very discrete data set and
as a result it's quite good at that one
thing right um so I think there's been
some been at least in conversations I've
had with people that are working to
develop these there's been kind of a
movement towards that I was struck by
the thing you commented on early in your
presentation about that the there was
was one amateur chess player or
something who found one little
Innovation that nobody had found and he
was able to then beat the the large the
learning model you know 19 out of 20
times or something you know because the
computer is just following its
instruction set right it's following its
learning model and but somebody goes hey
wait a minute if I do this I upset it it
reminded me of the uh the self-driving
taxis and I can't remember where it is I
think it's in is it New Orleans or
something where somebody found if they
take a a traffic cone one of those
orange traffic cones and they put it on
the hood of the of the car as a joke it
stops the car the car does not know how
to handle that and it stops dead in its
tracks and they create traffic jams it's
like you know who thought of that that's
amazing but it it's means now that they
have to go back retrain their models and
say you know ignore traffic cones yeah
and then think about the think about the
differences between like the computer
vision space that would be needed to
have an automated car have enough
density of information to understand and
interpret every potential scenario that
it could run into I mean that again
seems Seems infinite you know and uh
maybe that's why we you know the
realization of the dream of the
driverless car just really hasn't hasn't
shown up quite yet and and that example
with go um it was done by a research
firm in um affiliated with Stanford um
and it was an amateur player and and I
don't I don't know the game go but
essentially what it did is created a you
know a perimeter around a particular
move and that if you are if you if it
was a human playing against a human it
would have recognized it immediately as
a you know kind of a fairly in
non-sophisticated
move inside the game and counteracted it
immediately but because the to your
point because the alphao had never seen
this you know it's kind of a kind of a a
move you would never make in personto
person play because it would be so
easily recognizable right that it
defeated the computer because it just
had never seen it before and so it's
this idea that we think about these
machines as intelligent but it's really
it's not it doesn't learn the rules of
the game it just learns patterns of
success so if a pattern of success
doesn't exist it doesn't have any
intuition about what the rules are to
defeat new methods and that's an
important thing it is intelligent in a
way but it not intuitive about the rules
or how to play the game only only super
understanding of the classical patterns
for Success which is a you know so you
can put quotations around intelligence
in that context at least from my
perspective yeah Ron what are the what's
the important elements here about making
and keeping Innovations in the
development of these models open
source yeah I mean there's a there's a
cultural Community associated with that
that reinforces it but I I I think that
that could be part of um I I think I'll
say this we used the use case of open AI
you know in kind of some of our
foundations courses because it was open
until it wasn't right until it was
evaluated as a as a billion doll
Enterprise and then now it's not a an
open- Source platform right so they went
private they started taking equity and
then they got bought by Microsoft so I
mean it so it it was a pretty easy
transition for them you know once it
became clear that you know there were
billions of dollars at stake but I think
like other I mean in other areas of our
economy you know you think about the
entire industry around ni and then how
we you know we don't deploy um you know
new medicines I mean even even around
accounting principles you know about
what it what's required in order for us
to be you know financial advisors things
like that I mean these might be extremes
but you really don't have any of that
relative to developing algorithms and
putting them out in the world or or you
know um you know data regulatory
oversight that seems like there should
be so I I think to a certain extent um
in order for this to be an open
conversation for continue to be you know
known um is that it's going to require
some type of governmental intervention
because the the dollars we're talking
about here are just too big um for you
know even even companies that have
idealistic idealistic uh origination
like open AI did to not suddenly go
private once it becomes
obvious that that's the the best the
best way for them to go and so I don't
know if I have a great answer for that
but I think to me there should be some
regulatory kind of um function that
allows um you know some oversight about
how these are being trained how they're
being deployed and then exactly what
methodologies they're using in order to
be able to keep an informed populace
about about how they're being used I
think that would be a healthy step no
Brian thank you so much for sharing uh
today and providing a context for
generative AI um especially as we go
down this uh Road of building
Partnerships between folks who are
developing generative AI methodologies
and the biomedical and clinical research
training that is soon to be following um
utilizing these methods thank you so
much for kicking us off and uh I want to
um thanks everybody who joined us out in
the world and uh please uh watch next
week uh when we have our next edition of
our biomedical data science uh
seminaries so thanks so much again Brian